l'histoire ne sais pas mais je sais
c'est très marrant nous sommes à
l'époque préhistorique
juste avant qu'un homme préhistorique
raconte à tout le monde ça formidable
découverte préhistorique se fait
beaucoup de fois préhistoriques comme ça
va wahou
elle est bien cette peau de bête tu l'as
trouvé ou sur une bête elle aimait
klemek et j'ai trouvé un truc
incroyablement bon à manger en fuyez
fuyez tous fouillés est là mais pourquoi
aller oui pourquoi alors je vais
t'expliquer pourquoi
regarde moi tes dangereux je suis quoi
je comprends vos oiseaux des dents je re
ok
la dernière fois que tu as trouvé qu'un
truc était bon ce qu'ils ont mangé sont
allongés après il parlait plus après
sentais super mauvais après sont devenus
tous malgré tout blanc
après on a fait des couteaux ah ouais tu
attaques sur ça et qu'est ce qui prouve
que c'est parce qu'ils ont mangé du caca
de mammouth et coupe six étaient
comestibles tous les animaux en
mangerait pas tous les animaux en
mangent mec banon vas-y banon ouah il
parle
ben oui c'est un perroquet dactyle wa tu
parles banon voici tu parles banon bah
si tu viens justement d'audrey second
degré non ça se dit quelque chose
ouah je viens de me faire bâcher par un
oiseau et je suis pas là deux semaines
il se passe trop de trucs
bon écoute je vais direct niveau
nourriture je te fais plus confiance
tu me fais plus quoi confiance c'est le
concept qu'on a tous voté la semaine
dernière
t'es chiant arrête de manger du cac à
evian réunion on essaie de faire
progresser l'espèce nous ah ouais tu
attaques sur ça et qui a découvert le
miel toi mais tu ne manges et que les
abeilles de dans away telle taxe sur ça
mais les ossètes on les trouvera plus
tard non non parce qu'on ne croit plus
là c'est fini on veut plus suivre
on a peur de toi non mais là ce que j'ai
trouvé c'est la meilleure boisson non et
non bon faut grimper un arbre non il
faut creuser dans un truc où il ya plein
d'autres trucs
truc je comprends plus là faut trouver
des noms aux trucs et ben viens aux
réunions et arrête de manger du caca jeu
c'est bon il faut s'approcher d'un
animal sauvage non mec je te dis c'est
facile c'est facile
ouais tout cas dit il faut sucer une
vache et tu bois leblanc je me casse
et c'est ainsi que depuis ce jour les
animaux ne nous ont plus jamais adressé
la parole
en tout cas d'après des chaussettes